let me go next to our caller from the five
three zero area code.
Who's calling today from five three zero.
Hi, I'm Charlie Mullinix.
I am a huge fan.
Hey Charlie, what's going on?
Um, I have two questions if that's okay.
Um, so I personally think a typical critical
at the right wing has this thing saying that
political correctness is it cancer?
Because I personally think the right wing
has, uh, has, uh, their own version of political
correctness.
Don't you think?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We've talked about it before.
Yeah, I mean, I mean, when you, when you think
about it, um, that this, this, um, utuber,
this conservative YouTuber, um, Hunter Avalon,
he's actually, he even talked about, um, uh,
you know how Alex Jones got banned from social
media and some other conservatives because
they, they violated terms of service and a
lot of the people who were right wing were
screaming about how the right wing is getting
sensor on social media and Hunter Avalon of
all people came out and said, um, no, this
is not really a right wing left wing issue.
This happens to everybody.
Um, have you heard of him?
I haven't heard of him, no.
Oh, he's, he's a pretty interesting guy.
I think.
I, I think you should debate them sometime.
Alright.
My name is Hunter Avalon.
Yep.
I got it.
I have a second question.
What's that?
I, I think I got the name.
Yeah.
What was your other question?
Um, this one is not necessarily political.
Is that okay?
Oh, that is okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, so in my area, I'm, I'm a local solo artist.
Um, I was wondering if you wanted to check
out two of my singles that I have released.
Sure.
Send them over to me by email, but I am going
to move on now because we do have a lot of
people who have questions, but you can email
them to me and I will gladly check them out